all right we're taking you now live to
oslo where at any moment we're expecting
the nobel
peace prize committee to announce
the prize for 2021
here apparently here they are let's
listen into the announcement who is the
winner of this year's
nobel peace prize
good morning
the norwegian nobel committee
has decided
to award the nobel peace prize for 2021
to
maria ressa
and dimitri muratov for their efforts
to safeguard freedom of expression
which is a precondition
for democracy and lasting peace
ms ressa and mr muratov
are receiving the peace prize
for their courageous fight
for freedom of expression in the
philippines
and in russia
at the same time
they are representatives
of all journalists
who stand up for this idea in a world in
which democracy and freedom of the press
face
increasingly adverse conditions
maria ressa uses freedom of expression
to expose abuse of power
use of violence
and growing
authoritarianism in her native country
the philippines
in 2012 she co-founded rutler
a digital media company
for investigative journalism which she
still heads
as a journalist and rappler ceo
resa has shown herself
to be a fearless defender of freedom of
expression
rappler has focused critical attention
to the duterte regime's
controversial
murderous anti-drug campaign
the number of deaths
is so high that the campaign resembles a
war
waged against the country's own
population
ms resa
and rappler have documented how social
media is being used to spread fake news
harass opponents
and manipulate the public discourse
dimitri
andreiwich
miratov
has for decades
defended freedom of speech in russia
under increasingly challenging
conditions
in 1993
he was one of the founders of the
independent newspaper
naviagaseta since
1995
he has been the newspaper's
editor-in-chief for a total of 24 years
nevaya gazetta is the most independent
newspaper in russia today
with a fundamentally critical attitude
towards power
the newspapers
fact-based journalism and professional
integrity
have made it an important source of
information
on sensorable aspects of russian society
really mentioned by other media
since its startup in 1993
nawaya gazeta has published critical
articles on subjects
ranging from corruption
police violence
unlawful arrests
electoral fraud and troll factories
and to the use of russian military
forces
both within and outside of russia
novaya gaseta's opponents have responded
with harassment threats violence and
murder
since the newspapers start
six of its journalists have been killed
including anna politkovskaya
who wrote revealing articles on the war
in chechnya
despite the killings and threats
editor-in-chief muratov
has refused to abandon the newspaper's
independent policy
he has consistently defended the right
of journalists
to write anything
about whatever they want
as long as they comply with the
professional and ethical standards
[Music]
and there we have it folks an
announcement
for the nobel peace prize of 2021 and as
a matter of fact we have
two winners announced maria ressa and
dimitri muratov
two journalists who are being awarded
the peace prize for
as the committee put it their courageous
fight for the freedom of speech in
defense of freedom of speech
now they're continuing to
address the decisions
behind the thinking for awarding the
prize jointly to two recipients this
year
but we heard there
an explanation
so far that
why maria ressa had received this prize
a distinguished filipino journalist
because
the nobel committee said she'd shown
herself as a fearless defender
of freedom of expression
and in terms of
mr dmitry muratov
being awarded the prize
we were told because he stood up for
freedom of speech in russia despite
threats and killing let's listen back in
firmly anchored in the provisions
of alfred nobel's will
thank you very much
uh madam chair um i don't know whether
to say congratulations or thank you
[Music]
and i think what we've always tried can
you do in journalism accountability
journalism
uh investigations that will hold power
to account it's just become far more
difficult um with the advent of
technology and social media and the way
social media has allowed
budding authoritarians and dictators to
be to exploit their algorithms and uh
all right let's take this now to rory
challenge he's live for us at that
announcement in oslo so
is that a bit of a surprise there was a
lot of talk about perhaps uh greta
thumbberg or svetlana
uh winning the prize but it it went to
two journalists can't say we're
disappointed of course at all
well if you're going to quote
margaret thatcher the british former
prime minister the unexpected always
happens and i think with the nobel peace
prize
that is very much the case there is
often uh with the nobel peace prize uh a
slightly left field candidates a group
that comes out from uh slightly lower
down the list of uh bookies favorites
and and comes in there so yes the these
two uh
new laureates uh were not
at the top of the list of those who
people who watch
the nobel peace prize year in the year
out were expecting as you say greta
tunberg the the swedish climate change
activist was one of those atlanta t
kenosha the better russian opposition
politician she was one as well then
there was the who the world health
organization for its work
over the last year in combating
the covert pandemic that was in you know
considered to be a forerunner what we
have here are two journalists working in
different countries different uh parts
of the world
of course what they share
essentially is working
to
highlight injustices
around the world and in their particular
corners of the world and i think it
shows perhaps what the
norwegian panel of the peace prize
consider to be you know one of the big
issues of modern times which is the
freedom of the press and the ability of
journalists to go about their work uh
unhindered as she was uh saying there uh
berets uh writes nielsen when she was uh
reading out this award um the the
russian laureate uh works for as the
editor-in-chief of nevada gazietta a
long-standing
independent newspaper magazine based in
russia
has been under enormous pressure over
the years
many of its journalists have been
injured jailed or even killed like anna
pollackovskaya um the famous russian
journalist who was shot dead in the
stairwell of her apartment block many
years ago so it just kind of goes to
show what kind of things the
norwegian nobel
team have been looking at and think are
serious issues that need to be
highlighted at the moment
and definitely there's a message being
sent here rory in in giving the prize
to two journalists at this point in time
right
all right i'm not sure if cory can hear
us sorry i didn't get that question
could you right yeah i'm saying there's
definitely a very clear message
of being sent here rory can you hear me
[Music]
just about i'm afraid yeah
voice is coming in and out of my ear so
i can hear about every every other
syllable um
all right well i'll tell you what rory
we'll come back to you later then let's
move on now and discuss it with
christian herbal zeimer director of the
international catalan institute of peace
joins us now from barcelona good to have
you with us first of all your reaction
to this
i guess you could call it a bit of a
surprise announcement
um i'm not sure it's a it's a it's a
surprise the names are certainly
surprised but the idea of
highlighting the relevance of freedom of
expression and the shrinking space of
for critical thinking in many countries
in the world was among the topics that
clearly were on the list and therefore i
think it's actually a very interesting
and positive
combination
it's interesting that the the
chairman of the committee in announcing
the decision highlighted not only the
efforts that they've made to defend
freedom of expression but did mention
sort of the the idea that they champion
fact-based journalism that says
something about the concern there is for
what is happening not only to freedom of
expression
but what is happening within the world
of journalism itself right with some
quarters being accused of leaning more
towards
well fake news rather than fact news
driven agendas
exactly so the whole fake news has
become a big topic in any country in the
world
from authoritarian countries to
the most developed democracy it is a
topic
therefore of of global concern
and by awarding the prize to these two
people i think it sends a number of
messages certainly for
the governments in the countries
through
our east live and work um but i think
far beyond that as well for the rest of
the globe
the relevance and the importance of
of press
of journalism and the fact that
journalists are harassed or killed
in many countries in the world and by
giving their work mariaresa
they become i think champions for more
global cause
does it also
there was some criticism leading up to
this about the lack of diversity and how
most of not all of the recipients so far
at least of i think the eight scientific
prizes went
to exclusively male recipients
does this balance it out a little
it does a little the
the nobel peace prize awards have been
throughout history
uh male dominated as the other awards
although it's important to say that an
award that started in
1902 cannot be taken
the third or fourth edition was already
given to a woman
although subsequently
during many years and it was awarded the
executive to men i think there has been
a significant effort these past years to
to have a gender balance and i think
they have achieved it fully with um with
this with his heart
and
an award like this what does it mean for
a journalist's ability to be able to
continue the sort of struggle which mr
muratov and uh miss
ressa are engaged in in in the one hand
you can obviously see
the recognition
and the the support that would come from
this prize
is there a downside to it does it enable
detractors from them maybe powerful uh
circles of powers and governments to say
well you're
simply a tool of the of a western
institution or a western agenda
um there is a a an obvious risk i mean
these two persons very arrested morado
and their colleagues in the philippines
russia and elsewhere are already
a target of criticism and harassment
from government authorities this will
make them more visible
and
would be likely a
public battle
that would decrease with this nomination
because the
critical voices against
authoritarian
governments and these governments will
not be happy with these nominations and
they will certainly accuse them of be
instrumental to foreign interests but
that i think is common to any
um human rights defender
naming and blaming human rights abusers
so that's part of the the game i would
say unfortunately
but i think it has many more positives
and um in the case of the philippines
for instance in a very short time frame
one there has been two big news that uh
affects what the
um nobel peace
committee designs as a government that
murders government that uh
wages a war against the country's own
population that's the words
she she used well um this has been um
going
without international disability and now
with this award and also very recently
the international criminal court has
started an official investigation into
the war on drugs in the philippines and
the government's responsibility this
will have a big impact in the
philippines um with upcoming elections
next year and i would say and they
insist also far beyond the philippines
there are a number of people of
journalists who do very work in
different difficult conditions who are
harassed or get killed in central
america and africa and many other places
in the world and um i think this is a
prize that
it's for all of them as well
and in its history of course there have
been many journalists who have received
the nobel peace prize this isn't the
first time that we're seeing
journalists receive
the nobel peace prize which is obvious
you know it's a good thing obviously as
journalists were
very happy and excited with that is this
time a little bit different whereas many
of the past recipients received the
nobel peace prize because of their
contribution towards peace you could you
know look at a lot of them from the days
of ernesto moneta in 1907 to tawakkul
karman i think in you know a few years
ago and there's that sort of common
thread
is this one different because now
journalists are receiving the nobel
peace prize because they've just been
able to stand up for journalism for
freedom of expression
um freedom of expression and i would say
democracy a bigger sense the trend in
the nobel peace prize you can see has
gone to people who have been actively
engaged in settlement
of conflicts
and that has often whenever there's been
a piece a big peace agreement in the
world and the latest one was the one in
colombia there's been this has been
rewarded with the nobel peace
award it happened also
between independence in israel palestine
it happened
in east timor it happened wherever there
has been a major settlement of
an armed conflict or political dispute a
second trend is human bodies and
the nobel peace committee is very
supportive of multilateral approach to
global
justice and therefore last year we had
the the whole food program and in
previous years very often um you and
different kinds of us bodies and the
third big trend is initiatives
that
support um that challenge militarization
arms race and these kinds of issues
which is always a trend right now there
is no this right now these past years
there haven't been any major
developments in peace
peace negotiations peace agreements
peace implementation unfortunately
and
then other issues come up and this could
have been climate change and this um
could have been and is actually
democracy
the quality of democracy is shrinking in
many places in the world and i would say
philippines is one of them philippines
became a world champion for democracy
when they had a non-violent massive
people's power revolution that um
toppled uh certainly marco's
dictatorship back in 86 and became
a world reference of
non-violent
people's struggle right and this is now
being this trend is being reversed
democracy is under threat in the
philippines in russia and in many other
places in the world and there i think
the issue of freedom of expression in
the role of journalists
that's the framework
from what we have to analyze this peace
prize
all right thank you so much it's been
wonderful getting your comments on this
thank you pleasure